welcome to eight crazy nights are you
ready to play chess with death yeah but
what does this mean for all of us I do
not know okay I've run out of lies no he
just comes in like sitting like this I
was just like well okay since what we're
doing so he's like let's just do I
thought we should talk to each other
more
nah it's about that that's not about us
well maybe it's about both yeah
actually that's very profound what you
just said blew my mind this really was
like a Swedish art Houseman yeah I'll
give me the blow um oh the hell are we
talking about a crazy night uh
you okay here's the flight thing before
I even talk about this movie of the
director tweeted uh review of it just
now just not right now
no like last last year and he's he
pretty much wrote this really nice tweet
saying I've sort of come to grips with
this movie and that's the only way you
can well T winter soon was to come to
grips with it he said when it first came
out I really didn't take the criticism
well but now the years have passed and
that I look back on uh you know it's
this is actually a really plain review
that's come out and I contacted him and
I said here's here's my question do we
know if that means he thought it was a
good movie and therefore didn't take
criticism well or he knew it was a bad
movie and just wasn't taking it well
because he's like I got a business well
I contacted him and I found out cuz he's
a really nice guy uh and I just was just
saying like you know that thanks for the
tweet and the shadow is very big of you
and he sent back just this really long
really cool email just talking about
this be my confession nobody he liked
and he talked about he sort gave like a
brief history and in animation they went
through and he he served like talk
praise about some people it smack about
others and I won't go into detail about
them we said was bad but one of the
things he said is that he said Adam
Sandler was hands down the
nicest person he's ever met in his life
he knew everything about everyone that
worked on a movie as other families were
doing and stuff like that
SWE's person in the world and he said
that he thinks he attached some of that
likeability to the movie which is very
understandable uh but he also said like
you know there's stuff like with the
with the film that he wanted to keep out
but it tested well and one of the
interesting things is that the worst
part in my opinion is anybody listen to
focus groups no but yeah here's the
interesting thing
how did he tell you stay in your lane
how many people you think go into focus
groups and then just troll like we're
just like oh I love this silly voice the
reindeer poop scene was the best doctor
but that's what's so funny is that those
two scenes you know they said the whitey
voice everyone hated it but then when
they said okay we'll change I was like
oh no no don't change it that's what
you're getting from focus groups and
again he he he was talking about he
didn't like the shit eating deer and
that stuff buddy's tested well gotta
keep it in uh so we're very anti focus
group if you haven't noticed um but but
we're not anti changing things you know
the The Matrix sequels clearly show
changed some stuff they're like no just
go do what I do it has it now look at
imeem when you think of focus groups
look at the typical youtube comment
section and just apply that to focus
groups it's like how many people are
there just fucking with you
I think people suddenly give in like a
position of like authority and power
maybe cuz they don't get much of it in
everyday life even for something or
deserve it yeah but even something like
a movie it's like why are the power and
I I
I think I'm gonna exercise some of my
authority and so on so forth and I think
they want to get out some of the straw
watch more reindeer eating shit please
no it's like they want control over
something even it's just like a movie
like they can have the power to change
something so it's like they want to
change their major you really want more
reindeer eating shit no but I can want
before importing it um so but but he
also liked the review because we did
really glorify the animation aspect
which the animation best if you ting
it will work if it weren't for that
animation it may be the worst thing
we've ever seen reviewing a like I don't
know if I I don't haven't quite go that
fine I would say maybe top 10 I don't
know I kind of a big made honestly okay
may let's pretend that for some reason
the animation was really ugly okay but
the but butchers not see you know no but
I'm saying I said if it weren't for the
animation did you hear my he'll forgive
God if it weren't for the animation I
think this would be Garbage Pail Kids
bad like I I'm sorry it just was so
inseparable to get through that stupid
whitey voice oh my god that was one of
the hardest things is the fact that was
supposed to feel for that care base
written like this compassion character I
mean and that's the worst thing about it
is that if you really wanted to be like
this dark messed up bad taste holiday
comedy fine but don't suddenly try to
throw in a heart and be like no this was
our plan isn't it clever the way we did
this no you're not talented enough to do
that or no I take it back
Adam Sandler is he can have us feel for
him in some movies while also doing some
bad taste stupid Joe but he needs a good
script yeah I mean I sure he you know
helps create it and write it and stuff
but it's like yeah he can do it uh I
don't know what it is that you know feel
that pushes him to not do it or did have
this bad balance that never seems to
work out oh maybe it's the Rob Schneider
influence baby oh maybe he's like the
devil whispering is here Manny the
reindeer deanship
hey know what the three feet rails so um
yeah it's one of those things where it's
like I've seen a I'm saying we do good
stuff this director has done really
great stuff um yeah even worked it he
worked on Family Guy worked on the
Looney Tunes show uh he was even saying
like he was offered some of these like
live-action films based like no I don't
want a lot I want to be good I want to
be as good as possible and I think maybe
there is something like when going into
a movie and you're just sir told hey
we're gonna make this beautiful looking
you know how to cook film which you
don't see there's so few films about
Holly
anymore okay yeah uh but sorry this idea
of hey I want this to look gorgeous and
beautiful and it's man Sandler film Adam
Sandler is big money it's like it'd be
hard to turn this down it's the best
review I ever read was somebody argued
that the damage it does to Hanukkah
probably means this is an anti-semitic
movie this is like yeah you can probably
make an argument but I think there's
some felt it's like a film on its own is
really tough to like is this working is
this not and you're you know because it
is such a big project it takes so much
time now for animation on that where
it's just like you came and have a perk
just not just the voice of livery you
need like the movement of the hand to
move exactly this way and there's
nothing money I worry that two animators
depressing to me that when animation
fails because he's just like man and Ron
so much yeah so many dead trees lost so
many hours of drawing these things I was
like to continue imagine the animators
is being like yeah what you do it's like
I animated reindeer eating shit like
it's just like so much work thrown into
it John it was beautifully animated
reindeer eating yeah no I mean it was
and that's the tragedy of it it's like
all of that work thrown into it and it's
you know Adam Sandler doing a silly
voice and reindeer eating shit like I I
do wonder if this film had like maybe
like I wants a power puff girls style
animation so they wouldn't make it any
better with the humor work any better I
lean towards no I lean towards yes you
think so
I think part of the problem is it was
such pretty animation and so much kind
of a Disney style of doing things and
realistic looking like which I'm sure
they thought that would work like this
crude humor with beautiful Disney style
animation like that contrast would work
yeah but did the opposite because kind
of yeah we've made it just awkward and
uncomfortable view like it may have been
better if it had like a Powerpuff Girls
animation or something more like Ren &
Stimpy where it was really over the top
zany fast just in your face and but
getting as many laughs as possible as
quick as possible I think that actually
would have made it better now I wouldn't
save the movie no that's why I was
saying what it would it have saved now I
wouldn't have saved it but I mean I
think it would have been better and
I think would have been a little less
insufferable hmm at least it's like you
know man this is so crazy and out there
it's like hard to even like you know get
a grasp on it it's so strange uh uh yeah
you know guide the sir reality of it
yeah the animation been crazier but when
it's that realistic and that pretty it
just I'm just like it's just weird and
mean-spirited but not not haha this is
really mean-spirited way just you know
Wow fuck is wrong with you as well and I
think when they try to have us actually
care for the characters you know one you
give a terrible voice - but you supposed
to be the heart of the film and then
another was supposed to be like a
delinquent who you know finds the true
meaning of you know family and caring
for people and stuff like that so you
throw it in this film is just so
mean-spirited you know it's I think to
myself that this contrast of the pretty
animation and the mean-spiritedness
would have worked better if they
actually just totally cut out the heart
if they did it like the only Family Guy
episodes where an episode would end with
well Peter I hope you learned a valuable
lesson he just goes nope and it's like
if it had that kind of gradually yeah I
don't mind a dark comedy in fact
normally the darker the better I just it
wasn't funny
yeah dude funny comedy it's got to be
funny it wasn't funny in the heart
element you know did not match the
mean-spiritedness of the rest it did not
balance it out just that voice
I just even think like I get like
post-traumatic stress disorder thinking
about that voice actually like haunts me
I wake up sometimes like from a
nightmare and I hear that voice and it's
just like it haunts me like a nam
flashback way like I'm there I'm
watching it again though oh it's just a
dream it's just a dream
okay oh my god actually of what I think
you'd be okay with me saying this but
one of the things he of a director said
it's like you know you thought the YT
voices was annoying she's seen the tapes
we didn't use oh god oh god yeah that
was actually toned down the focus
crunches originally it was even more
play again more low
you know and it is important to bring up
that distinction when he was talking
about how what a nice guy Adam Sandler
is cuz you know there are times where
it's like the comedian's you hate the
most are the nicest guys I've heard
similar things about Larry the Cable Guy
yeah like he'll give me the shirt off
your back and he's like he's always
there for you and he's the nicest guy
and you know there's some comedians who
play nice guys and her total dicks so
when we do reviews like this you have to
separate like when we're talking about a
performance we're talking about a
performance not the person themselves
and I think I'm something I think that
some heat can't like - is that I did
want to bring up in there cuz it's like
when I hear there's really nice people I
think it is important to at least sort
of acknowledge that I did Adam Sandler
can't be funny and he can't be hartfeld
I think it's important Malik no look
this this can happen and has happened
and should be looked at and acknowledged
but it's just Sandler seems like the
kind of guy that I were at a bar and sat
next to him I could just start you know
like chatting with him drink a couple
beers seems like a nice guy you know and
but the characters he plays Mike I mean
he literally has made a career of mostly
playing jag-offs total fucking jag what
but they're not even really characters
are their voices you know and that's
sort of what bothers me too is that
they're not very well to file like I
said with the exception of you know one
or two guys I guess he can do drama but
it's just rare this one like you know
I'm just grateful for Hotel Transylvania
cuz I'm like okay he can do good voice
cuz like this film just oh my god one of
probably the most insufferable
performances I'm not saying Adam
Sandler's bad but when those
insufferable performances I ever had to
sit through in an animated film or any
film like any film and what's so ironic
is why he's a sister right thing I was
the sister uh there was am sama - if you
didn't tell me that I wouldn't be able
to guess he does that voice really now
like he can zoo voices he can see me but
I did I don't know I don't know what got
him started on well I mean Jesus Christ
like his work on a the late 90s and like
all of his stuff on CD they were always
noises no morning I would sure like I
guess somewhere it started and like I
had I lived forever had I have known
early on and I'm have we all known early
on that it was going to send them the
message to do nothing but this yeah I
think we all should have reconsidered
buying those CDs and me like on its
various cost you dumb 90s teen I liked
you know I love that they're all going
out your schedule I'll see if I get to I
can't oh it's not good but now like 15
20 years later we're just like Oh had we
known we wouldn't know but we would have
encouraged that we were like no you can
do more but and again we found out he
can it what hurts me the most honestly
more than him doing a bad comedy is when
he does a bad drama cuz it's like shit I
know this guy can do good drama he just
picked whatever a bad film or a bad
director or a bad script or something
and it's like but I'm sure he's fine you
know it's just like but yeah crab
because like I love to see him do more
serious stuff for more like different
kinds of college condom Club yeah I love
that um the last third of use more silly
voices the last third of click is like
heavily dramatic and actually kinda like
rips your heart out this guy like crap I
wish the rest of movie was like this
instead just the dumb fart joke gaming
going go I'm the Hulk
whoa it's like the last third reason
tanking again oh I'm the Hulk you know
and I think you can make a career and
maybe this as I don't
so oh so yeah it's one of those things
where it's like oh I see all this talent
in one place and it's not being utilized
I'll never quite figure out why I think
it's kind of what you said I think he's
sort of things like you know the kind of
funny voice you do in a bar and get a
lot of people laughing when you're just
in a silly mood it has its place but it
can we're very quickly and it's like
you've got this small cabal of fans and
decided I have to do nothing but please
these people only mm um and give Rob
Schneider work for Rihanna then I cannot
yeah I can't you just can't no I just
can't like I'm not willing to forgive
Adam Sandler for that I'll forget
even this movie I'll forgive but I won't
forgive uh so yeah it's definitely one
of those films where it's it's beautiful
to look at and I I think you saw argued
that's what makes it even harder to
watch is that you're seeing such wasted
potential
that's what was torturing me when I was
watching it I'm just like all of this
work all of this great animation I mean
that I'm not lying if you hit the mute
button
it's a gorgeous film man what'd I say
yeah you should either then that's I
told you that I'm like here Doug watch
this and we muted it for about 15
seconds
we're like oh this is just a really
pretty movie that's like maybe we can
make up our own plot like it's a silent
film Mike so if you do that it's not
that bad like it's really gorgeous to
watch but man turn the side oh you okay
oh yeah you just stop I'll fuckin end
you bitch stop as I'm not lying that
voice just ah well one of the parts that
like people are very split on in the
review is the really long phone call I
give kkona kkona and salmon which is you
doing a great impression of them uh and
some people are like oh my god it felt
so good to like just go full force and I
feel like oh my god that went way too
long I understand both that was just
okay own bit of therapy like no no I
just I gotta let this out cuz we had to
listen to an hour and a half of this
god-awful voice and sometimes you need a
death ursus oh yeah what it uh sometimes
you you just fucking but again we try to
show and and sailor in a good light
there's a okay there you've got a little
fire there um I thought it made it
funnier because of that like yes I'm
doing the silly voice so but yeah yeah
not not too much else to come around out
on this just like it's still it's it's
probably my top ten of the most
insufferable thing it might be top ten
for me yeah at least for the NC like
yeah um it was pretty hard to get
through but like I said the nice the the
gorgeous animation really does you know
it it does stop me from putting it like
whenever top five or something like that
because it really
beautiful and you can see the hard work
that went into it and even Adam saya I'm
sure is a hard worker he seems like a
guy that would be a really really hard
worker I just I don't get the I don't
get why still go going in this direction
I hope pixels is good please just have
that be like you know head to be a good
movie head like em sailing be genuinely
funny at it and then it's like oh god
like maybe I should do more of this
stuff and it's like yes please be just
be I mean the ripa don't Futurama that's
a good thing to rip off yeah exactly
yeah it is pretty much that it um so uh
yeah that's about it uh hope to see
better work from these downed people and
lo we have seen better work from both of
May I hope there's more better work from
the Hotel Transylvania - yes very
excited for that I hope that takes off I
hope it's just like maybe I should keep
doing this man you keep doing this the
directors going on to wonderful stuff uh
they definitely check out though he's
done a lot of TV and such so definitely
great work and yeah hopefully just more
good stuff keeps coming out these really
tell to people so uh we'll see you next
time take care